Saudi Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman
has been on an Asia trip all week it's
seen as a diplomatic pivot a way for the
Prince to prove that life goes on even
after Western countries started shunning
him following the murder of writer Jamal
Khashoggi last year his first stop had
been to Pakistan a country Saudi Arabia
has a close relationship with and where
he pledged to invest almost 18 billion
euros he visited India next where he
announced his country is ready to share
intelligence with New Delhi in the fight
against terrorism he stopped short of
making direct reference to last week's
terror attack in Kashmir he has had a
fine line to walk between Pakistan and
India and now bin Salman's on the final
stop of his trip China where he signed a
deal to build in oil refinery Saudi
Arabia is one of China's top crude oil
suppliers second only to Russia now the
House of Saud has long presented itself
as the defender of Muslims around the
world
given that Islam's two holiest sites
Medina and Mecca are there but during
this visit bin Salman has not said a
public word so far about China's
internment of as many as 1 million
meters a Turkic Muslim minority living
primarily in the country's far west it
is one of the most serious violations of
human rights happening in the world
today joining me now to talk more about
this is Isaac stonefish senior fellow at
the Asia Society
now Isaac you wrote a really interesting
Washington Post column about this about
bin Salman having an opportunity but
also writing at the same time that he
probably won't be taking the opportunity
so this is really a economic trip more
than anything a diplomatic trip more
than anything that's right I think we
can be idealistic and hopeful that
someone like NBS would bring up the
treatment of the weekers but know that
on such a trip which is dominated by
real politic and mbss desire to have a
better relationship with China most
specifically on issues involving trade
and
trying to find a way to somehow we news
countries off a reliance on oil as
opposed to having anything that would
come across as involving the situation
in chin John or anything about human
rights in general let's talk a little
bit more about the situation and she and
Jen for those people who don't know much
about it could you briefly just explain
what is going on so she's young is a
region in Far North West China where an
estimated 1 million Muslims are in
concentration camps that Chinese
government doesn't call them
concentration camps that talks about
them as reeducation centers for radicals
that need to learn how to operate in the
modern world but actually it really is a
massive atrocity where people are
equally in camps I mean their
concentration camps and for the leaguers
who are not in camps there's a really
dystopian surveillance system people's
phones are monitored their movements are
monitored and there's also a strong push
to D Islamize or sinus eyes the Islam
that Muslims practice in northwest China
so trying to move people away from
prayers and fasting and abstaining from
pork and alcohol and trying to make them
more Chinese this is really frankly
should be an outrage on at the
international level bin Salman won't be
talking about it has other countries in
Asia other countries other Muslim
countries talked about this at all
so MBS has good company in ignoring the
plight of the weekers Indonesia's Widodo
has not said anything
a prominent Malaysian politician very
vaguely brought it up I'm Lara Ibrahim
but he didn't really say anything I
think Pakistan's religious Minister has
said something but Imran Khan the Prime
Minister has certainly been silent about
this so Turkey is really the only
country that has said anything of
significance
the foreign ministry spokesperson
decried the crimes being committed there
but this is also a step down from what
air21 said in 2009 where he called it
genocide and since then and since China
has become more and more important
political and economic for countries
around the world I think everyone has
decided to be silent
Isaac stonefish thank you so much for
your time
you